merci pierre yves bonjour à tous merci
pierre rives de m'avoir demandé
d'intervenir devant vous ça fait huit
ans que je travaille avec lui sur le
terrain
bon j'avais créé une association ça
prenne de sécurité à l'époque et je peux
témoigner bande de son activisme et du
sérieux avec lequel bon il travaille
pour nos idées et pour nos habitants
alors mon propos sera assez bref je dois
dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut d'abord
parler vrai il faut parler vrai parce
que il ya cinq ans le président sarkozy
bon a fait voter à son initiative une
loi sur le grand paris qui prévoyait la
création de 70000 logements par an nous
sommes aujourd'hui environ 35 à 40 mille
logements par an dont il serait bon
c'est pour ça qu'il faut parler vrai que
tous les responsables politiques de
collectivités locales là se mettent en
ordre de marche pour aboutir bon à
creysse et 70000 logements donc dix
mille logements pour les classes
moyennes ou les classes intermédiaires
c'est un élément tout à fait essentiel
et malheureusement ce qui est
inacceptable c'est que nous n'arrivons
pas à mobiliser les élus et les autres
responsables dans ce domaine lors il ya
urgence
il y a urgence pour répondre aux besoins
de nos concitoyens à paris naturellement
les étudiants les jeunes les personnes
dites âgées parce qu'on ne sait pas à
partir de quand nous sommes âgés c'est
wii et wii fit beaucoup de débats dans
ce domaine mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'à paris beaucoup de gens veulent
partir de paris et que c'est une ville
qui est en train de perdre son énergie
alors quels sont les enjeux actuellement
par yves on l'a souligné il ya un
instant ses 105 kilomètres carrés ces
2,2 millions d'habitants
c'est à dire cinq fois moins qu'à vienne
en termes de territoire berlin 9 mois
neuf fois moins
donc c'est une ville où il y a peu de
moyens pour construire par contre il est
nécessaire de rénover il
ces serres de m les logements dans des
conditions de dignité de lutter contre
l'assument si les voilà merci
et ça ne sais pas c'est un élément qui
est fort il faut également lutter contre
contre la vacance alors un nouveau
dispositif va être mis en place dont
vous allez en entendre parler
la semaine prochaine qui est le
dispositif multi locke et qui va être
mise en place à notre initiative de
professionnels ensuite bien il faut
combattre l'encadrement des loyers bon
chaque tâche et curieux qu'on en parle
peu mais c'est un système totalement
contre-productif qui ne changera pas la
situation peut-être développera brand le
travail au noir c'est le pas le travail
au noir le paiement noir brrr le black
et ça personne n'en parle
les chiffres que vous voyez dans la
presse malheureusement ou heureusement
sont totalement faux on verra dans une
offre 10 mois deux mois ce qu'il en est
véritablement mais ça ne changera
vraiment pas beaucoup la situation par
contre ce dispositif est bien créer un
manque de confiance dans l'immobilier
et ça c'est le problème le plus délicat
dans le secteur de l'immobilier il y à
de nombreux acteurs qui interviennent
je vais parler des mères mais ensuite il
ya les promoteurs j'irai jusqu'à jusqu'à
laisse au bout de la chaîne de cette
chaîne les agents immobiliers les
syndics de copropriété ex terrain sur
cette chaîne de l'immobilier il faut
recréer bon un peu de fluidité et
surtout de la confiance pour mieux le
j'ai mon nos citoyens et puis
nécessairement dont il faut parler bon
de la région francilienne la région
francilienne le conseil régional c'est 5
milliards d'euros c'est en gros 200
millions d'euros pour le logement c'est
à dire que c'est une action à cfm
même si les remakes rail souligne dans
ses interventions que c'est un effet
démultiplicateur c'est vrai mais c'est
pas l'élément essentiel élément
essentiel est là je voudrais le
souligner je sais pas s'il est dans la
salle
rendre hommage à l'ancien préfet de
région d'île de france daniel canepa
il a mis en place les contrats de
développement territorial
mais ces contrats de développement
territorial il faut les généraliser
alors en quoi ça consiste
ça consiste à négociations entre les
collectivités locales et tous les
acteurs qui interviennent dans le
domaine du logement
c'est ça qui est important est de les
engager sur une durée longue de 6 ans
donc la lisibilité des marchés vont
peuvent ainsi se se présenter c'est un
point très important et nous nous
souhaitons véritablement un plus grand
développement de ces contrats de
développement territorial et puis comme
l'a souligné le la cour régionale des
comptes
il faut faire une évaluation des
politiques publiques en matière de
logement dans notre région
je vous invite fortement à lire ce
rapport vous en vous verrez enfin qu'on
s'intéresse puisque ça c'est également
très important qu'on s'intéresse au
logement de façon concrète dans notre
région lors ceci est dû certainement un
désengagement de l'état
ça nous l'avons vu encore récemment
et puis parce que peut-être dans les
acteurs ne se mobilise pas assez
suffisamment dans ce domaine alors je
préside la commission logement du medef
et donc nous venons de sortir
c'était jeudi dernier bon un rapport bon
d'autant pages sur le sujet qui rejoint
très largement le rapport de monsieur
fillon parce que c'est un rapport sur le
logement qui est excessivement bien
écrit et tout à fait tout à fait
courageuses
enfin ça sera mon dernier mot ne nous
oubliez pas après les élections
non on est là alors je sais que pierre
yves y veillera parce que nous voyons
régulièrement sur le terrain dans le 18e
nous ne nous oubliez pas et maintenez le
cap sur une vision claire parce que pour
mobiliser au mois de décembre
nos concitoyens quelle que soit leur
tendance politique sur ce sujet majeur
qui l'avenir de notre région
eh bien il faut être clair dans les
propositions qui sont faites et
s'engager même si elles sont modestes
allaient réaliser le plus rapidement
possible
merci de votre attention merci michel
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps